my wife was abducted I have to save her
that mirror force warps the mind until
the person is no longer recognizable if
iris is still alive in there there's
probably nothing left of her to save
where's he going Barry you're going the
wrong way wait for it
she's relieved to finally get rid of
godspeed and this one talks so now we
know we got the real log is heart behind
bars that's not the real Cosby once he
was placed in a meta dampening cell I
questioned him as the flash in all he
could say was the one who sent me wants
infinite velocity when you were fighting
Godspeed he said we deserve your speed
whose way this we include the one who
sent him he couldn't tell me because he
stopped talking and started chirping
like a broken modem just like the rest
I have an idea a way to get our people
out of the mirrors
we need a lossless self-sustaining
source of Perpetual energy sounds like
you're talking about the holy grail of
science and perpetual motion machine
that's right
Hartley had some ideas I think we can
actually build one we're just missing
one component and thanks to my travels I
know exactly where to find them
Atlantis finally crisis pays off in a
good way for once
guys get to work
[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my flash finale trailer
video that's right
episode 19 next week will be the finale
because the virus delayed everything and
they weren't able to finish filming the
rest of the episodes of this season so
we'll break it down there's a bunch of
Easter eggs if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos we're doing an Amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave all your
predictions for the flash season 7 on
the video so here we go team flash is
still trying to get everyone out of the
mirrored dimension that's right iris
everyone else is still trapped in there
I love that Joseph Carver is like your
wife is dead dude time to move on find
yourself somebody new there's this whole
subplot going on between him and his
wife the new mirror master which seems
like they want to kill each other like
he just abandoned her inside the mirror
dimension either she was trapped in
there then went crazy like iris is
slowly going crazy inside this trailer
or she was crazy before she went in and
he just used that as an excuse to trap
her in there but the whole thing is is
that now that cisco has an idea to get
them out of the mirror dimension but
it's going to require technology from
Aquaman at Atlantis so this isn't the
first time that they've mentioned
Aquaman and Atlantis on the TV show you
remember way back in season 2 the first
time they ever name-dropped it was when
a zoom pretending to be Jay Garrick from
earth-2 said that there was a version of
Atlantis on earth - I love the joke from
elongated man who says crisis finally
pays off in a good way that's just a
joke about them getting closer to TV
Justice League doing the big Justice
League characters Aquaman being the next
they've done a version of famous Kira we
have a Superman TV show via Tyler
hoechlin coming later this year so we're
just that much closer to doing actual TV
justice league in not just the
Superfriends which is what happened at
the end of crisis but Cisco's idea is to
use a perpetual motion machine which is
a real thing it's a concept that's been
around for a long long time in the real
world this is what it looks like it kind
of reminds you the giant circular device
the magnetron the zoom was forcing Barry
to run around and activate during the
flash season two finale running around a
giant circle because that's what the
flash does he runs around stuff the
difference in that finale is that zoom
was trying to destroy all the worlds in
the multiverse except for earth one this
time team flash is just trying to cross
into the mirror dimension between
barriers Cisco even started to talk more
about
multiverse concepts like maybe this is
just another earth in the multiverse
that we can travel to using my vibe
abilities they got really weird with
that whole multiverse explainer after
crisis pretending like the multiverse
didn't exist anymore even though we saw
that whole post-credit scene leading up
to the Superfriends scene at the end
around the table the whole idea is that
it was the rebirth of the multiverse so
we're not really sure why the characters
are in the dark about the multiverse
existing they still think that it's not
a thing oh we're the only earth there
are no other copies of other people
whatever's happening in the finale and
during season 7 I'm assuming that that's
when they'll discover that there really
is a multiverse that's back it's just
very different than what it looked like
before
like they use crisis and the earth prime
reboot to put all the heroes on the same
earth in some of the heroes and villains
look a little bit different they'll
probably do the same thing with other
worlds in the multiverse when they start
revealing that but then there's this
whole godspeed subplot godspeed in the
episode was voiced by BD Wong again from
Gotham and Jurassic world so I'm happy
that they brought him back like Morena
Baccarin is still doing the voice of
Gideon even though they haven't really
done Gideon in a long time either but
this scene at the end of the episode
mostly confirms that God speed is gonna
be a big villain or the main villain of
season 7 the real version quote-unquote
of August heart Barry said that when he
was fighting this version of God speed
he said that they quote-unquote
multiples they were looking for infinite
speed and had developed a technique for
stealing Speed Force from other
speedsters there was a little different
from the technique that earth 90 Barry
Allen used during crisis on Infinite
Earths on our Barry when he stole his
speed to use the cosmic treadmill you
run long enough kid you learn a couple
new tricks the showrunner said that
they're doing a lot more stories from
the newer flash rebirth comics and at
the beginning of the flash rebirth
comics there's a Scott Speed storyline
with him going around killing other
speedsters taking their speed so they're
just trying to do a slightly different
version of that on the TV show but this
god speed is just another advanced
cybernetic copy of the last fake god
speed we saw at the beginning of the
season in episode 1 confirming that the
real August heart is still out there
coming back during season 7 to be a much
bigger villain the reason why they're
probably doing that is so that they can
cast a much bigger actor when they
reveal the real August heart and it'll
be someone that we haven't seen before
but they always tease the villain of the
season in the last couple of episodes of
the previous season like oh this person
is gonna be a big deal next year but
just because God speed seems like he's
gonna be the big villain of season seven
doesn't mean he'll be the only villain
because there's also that big hanging
plot thread with reverse-flash the twist
that Grant Gustin said was originally
supposed to happen in the real finale
episode 22 I believe but because of the
virus they couldn't film it so I think
we all assumed that was going to lead up
to a big red death storyline or a big
twist I've already talked about that in
previous flash videos but there's also
the blood work hanging plot thread to
the mirror copies tried to free him a
couple episodes ago but he said no no no
I'm gonna stay in here I'm playing the
long game there's other ways for me to
be free so obviously if they don't
resolve that in the finale they'll have
to bring him back during season seven so
the showrunner and Grant Gustin himself
confirmed that they probably will just
wrap up all that stuff that they
couldn't film at the end of this season
at the beginning of season seven and
then do the story that they had
originally planned for the beginning of
season seven Grant Gustin did a big
interview with the DC comics people last
week saying that he already knew what
their whole plan was for the season
seven story and for all the characters
and the new villains so they'll do all
that stuff at the beginning of the
season and even though his contract is
up they had started discussions with the
studio about doing a season eight in
season nine possibly but because of the
virus the talks had stopped and he said
he's not sure when they're going back to
film season seven and when they're gonna
start negotiating his new contract again
but he did a biga long podcast with
Michael Rosenbaum also talking about
leaving the show because Michael
Rosenbaum if you remember left
Smallville as Lex after season seven
he's like I did seven seasons that's
good enough for me then for the rest of
the show up to the series finale I just
came back every once in a while for
cameos
so naturally he asked Grant Gustin do
you feel like leaving the show like
seven seasons is enough so Grant Gustin
just said that he'd be happy either way
either leaving the show or doing more
they're gonna have to pay him way more
money when he renews his contract so
that's a big consideration but they did
that for Stephen Amell they paid him a
crazy amount of money to do arrow season
eight but what's gonna happen with DC TV
the week after the flash finale is the
star girl TV show is just gonna replace
the flash on Tuesday nights and it'll
run for 13 episodes I've seen the first
three episodes already it's basically
Justice Society TV show with a real
version of a Justice Society but it's
different actors playing the characters
than the Justice Society characters
you've seen in the DC TV universe so
it's a little bit different I'll do a
video for episode 1 in a couple weeks
when they actually dropped that first
episode and then a lot of you have also
asked me to do a Justice League dark
apocalypse war video they just released
that movie video on demand my video for
that will post later this week so as
long as you have alerts enabled for my
channel you should see that when I post
it but it was actually a pretty solid
movie there's also a new Deadpool 3
video that I'll post later tonight too
because Ryan Reynolds was going off
about Deadpool 3 recently so while you
wait for that everyone click here for my
new spider-man 3 daredevil clip and
click here for that new Rick and Morty
season 4 episode 7 trailer video thank
you so much for watching everyone stays
safe I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]